ein impfzwang erst recht nicht für die
jüngsten und damit wir alle als
gesellschaft wirklich gut aus dieser
pandemie rauskommt ist es wahnsinnig
wichtig dass wir diese impfquote
ankurbeln
[Musik]
näher am tor wenn wir uns jetzt mal vor
augen führen wir haben sommer 20 21
anderthalb jahre nach beginn der
pandemie und die bundesregierung will
immer noch nicht ausschließen für den
herbst dass es wieder zu wechseln
unterricht kommen sollte kommen könnte
ist das nicht ein armutszeugnis für die
politik ja also ich sehe das mit sehr
großer sorge für uns muss klar sein dass
und der befund ist glaube ich
parteiübergreifend richtig das natürlich
eine riesen zäsur war für die schüler
für die studenten die teilweise jetzt ja
seit mehreren semestern noch nie einen
vorlesungssaal von innen gesehen haben
deswegen haben wir insbesondere für die
schüler auch das aufholen paket
aufgelegt und wichtig ist
schulschließung müssen die absolute
ultima ratio sein aber sie haben recht
an vielen stellen und der ball geht
eindeutig an die länder sind die
bildungsministerien da nicht optimal
vorbereitet worden schließlich das spd
bildungsministerium mecklenburg
vorpommern ausdrücklich ein das hat
durchaus sorgen gemacht und bewegt die
menschen aber der vorwurf geht natürlich
auch an die bundesregierung der ja auch
nicht unmaßgeblich beteiligt ist im mtk
beschluss wenn man da mal ganz genau
rein guckt da gibt es von den zehn
punkten zum thema pandemie nicht einen
konkret zur schule nur eine kleine
fußnote auf die übrigens thüringen
gedrängt hat ist es eine angemessene
prioritätensetzung naja das hat vor
allem damit zu tun und das ist immer das
spannende bei den mpk beschlüssen
spannend das haben sie herausgearbeitet
ist das was nicht drinsteht das hat auch
damit zu tun weil die länder natürlich
sehr selbstbewusst sagen wir wollen
nicht dass der bund uns hier reinredet
und wir wollen auch nicht dass das auf
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen
einheitlich geregelt wird ich glaube
aber für diese art und weise des
bildungsföderalismus gibt es nicht sehr
viel verständnis ich bin kein freund
davon alle bildungskompetenzen auf die
bundesebene zu heben aber
einheitlichkeit und lösungen musste
schon geben und das ganze thema der
schule schafft im moment sehr sehr viel
verunsicherung und da müssen wir
definitiv nacharbeiten dieser vorwurf an
die bundesländer der trifft natürlich
indirekt oder direkt die grünen das
würde ich gerne mal zu ihnen mit
übernehmen frau schäfer die grünen
regieren
bundesländern mit wenn wir mal in ihr
wahlprogramm reinschauen da steht das
zitieren wir mal kinder und jugendliche
haben in der pandemie besondere
verzichts leistungen erbracht die
einschränkung von kontakten trifft sie
in ihren entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
härter als erwachsene können sie denn
als grüne mit der ganzen mit
regierungsverantwortung garantieren dass
es nicht mehr zu wechseln unterricht
kommt egal was da noch passiert also ich
glaube das wichtige ist dass die politik
jetzt das versprechen macht dass wir die
voraussetzungen schaffen und damit
schulschließungen im herbst nicht
notwendig sind und dass die auch die
letzte maßnahme sind wie bei kontakt
beschränkungen dann ergriffen werden wir
haben es ja gerade gehört ganz viele
kinder und jugendlichen haben in einer
ganz wichtigen phase ihres lebens eben
kaum unterricht gehabt da sind auch
einfach perspektiven verloren gegangen
die uns auch wahnsinnig lange noch
beschäftigen werden und genau deswegen
verstehe ich auch nicht warum sich nicht
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
von der bundesregierung darauf geeinigt
werden konnte dass wir zum beispiel
jetzt die schulen endlich zu sicheren
orten machen massiv die luftreinhaltung
konzepte ausbauen die pcr tests ausbauen
um dann dafür zu sagen ist einfach die
voraussetzungen da sind damit unterricht
auch stattfinden kann manchmal doch da
gleich mal ein bisschen expertise rein
herr maske kinder als aus berlin ist bei
uns herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr maske sie sagen die schulschließung
auch und auch die verbote von
freizeitaktivitäten die haben am ende
mehr schaden angerichtet als das virus
an sich
ja ein glück durch das virus kaum
belastet sie infizieren sich meist
gleich häufig ungefähr wie erwachsene
aber sie erkranken sehr viel seltener
die sekundären folgen durch locker und
et cetera sind sehr viel höher wir sehen
also sehr viel kinder mit adipositas
also versucht mit
psychiatrischen problemen wie
zwangsstörungen depressiven störungen et
cetera und diese schäden sind sehr viel
deutlicher als die folgen der infektion
und jetzt kommt das thema impfen impfen
für kinder hin zu bzw für jugendliche da
mischt sich die politik jetzt will ich
auch so ein bisschen ein wie sehen sie
das ja das einmischen der politik in
diese in die medizin ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht akzeptabel
natürlich hat die politik ein interesse
dass das deutsche volk gesund bleibt
sozusagen aber das jetzt auf die kinder
wieder abzulassen und auch die
jugendlichen die an dieser pandemie
einfach schon sehr viel geleistet haben
sie haben anderthalb jahre
verzichtet und zwar für die älteren
generationen damit diese nicht erkranken
oder sogar sterben das ist jetzt
tatsächlich nicht gut dass dort auch
druck ausgeübt wird auf die kinder und
jugendlichen der druck der ist ja vor
allem in den letzten zeit auch ausgeübt
worden auf die ständige impfkommission
stiko und da hat ihre partei am tor
unter anderem auch mitgemacht ganz vorne
mit dabei markus söder aus der
schwesterpartei csu
der hält sich ja ganz offensichtlich
schon für den besseren kanzlerkandidaten
ist ja jetzt auch noch der bessere arzt
also markus söder ist ein hervorragender
ministerpräsident und ein hervor an der
csu-vorsitzende werden mit armin laschet
auch einen sehr guten kanzlerkandidaten
das vorweg zu der frage verhältnis von
medizin und politik stehen wir wie so
oft vor dem dilemma dass es
unterschiedliche beurteilungen gibt und
wir haben auch im feld sozusagen der
kinderärzte sehr sehr unterschiedliche
perspektiven zu der frage wie man mit
kinderimpfungen umgeht wie man insgesamt
mit impfungen von jugendlichen umgeht
und deswegen will ich nur sagen halte
ich es für richtig dass wir da keine
klare festlegung gemacht haben dass wir
die grundsätzliche direktive haben zu
sagen es ist wünschenswert wenn wir eine
hohe impfquote haben das ist der weg aus
der pandemie aber keinen impfzwang erst
recht nicht für die jüngsten aber so
nimmt ja ein gremium dafür das ist ja
die stiko sollte dass er entscheiden ist
es gut oder ist es schlecht finden sie
es richtig politisch druck auf diese
leute aus also ich habe nicht den
eindruck dass man da politischen druck
ausgeübt hat die sind frei in ihrer
beurteilung und die stiko hat gesagt
dass man es der individuellen
beurteilung der kinderärzte überlassen
soll und das finde ich persönlich auch
richtig ich würde für mich als politiker
nicht in anspruch nehmen der bessere
mediziner zu sein das besser zu bewerten
und ich sehe und das erlebe ich auch aus
dem persönlichen umfeld in den
gesprächen im wahlkreis dass einige für
ihre kinder entscheiden ja das soll
gemacht werden andere sind dagegen und
genau diese freiheit und diese expertise
auch der ärzte die sollten wir
einbeziehen frau schäfer aus ihrer
partei kämpfen kritik an den mpk
beschlüssen man müsse jetzt mehr tempo
machen beim impfen dann üben sie doch
schon mal regieren werden sie ganz
konkret sollen die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen sich impfen lassen ja oder
nein also mir geht es auch so dass ich
da auf das votum der ärzte und ärzte
vertrauen und ich glaube dass das ganz
wichtig dass wir einfach ein angebot
machen und die entsprechenden
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten bereitstellen
und das angebot wurde aus meiner sicht
noch nicht flächendeckend genug gemacht
sowohl für kinder und jugendliche als
auch für erwachsene menschen wir haben
30 millionen ungeimpfte personen in
deutschland und einer heranrollende
delta variante und damit wir alle als
gesellschaft möglichst gut aus dieser
pandemie rauskommen ist es natürlich und
natürlich auch die schulen offen bleiben
kann und die universitäten ist es
wahnsinnig wichtig dass wir diese
impfquote ankurbeln und ich verstehe zum
beispiel nicht warum wir jetzt die
gelder die in diesem zentrum gesteckt
worden sind nicht einfach in mobile im
angebote investieren bei mir im
wahlkreis gibt es zum beispiel in einem
stadtviertel einen im bus der an allen
orten lokalisiert ist weil das geld
fehlt zum beispiel in die wohngebiete zu
fahren da verstehe ich nicht warum
können wir nicht das geld was wir jetzt
schon investiert haben dahin packen
damit dass der impfstoff quasi zu den
menschen kommt nicht wir erwarten dass
die menschen zum impfstoff kommen eine
klare klare empfehlung war es jetzt
nicht an der stelle wir wollen eine frau
koch mit rein nehmen und fragen wie
diskutieren sie das denn mit ihren
mitschülerinnen und mitschülern
also auch dich geschafft hat natürlich
über das thema oft geredet
ich wie ich es als schülerin mitbekommen
hab meinem umfeld ging es nicht
insbesondere um die gesundheitlichen
auswirkungen dass man dann geschützt
sondern es ging tatsächlich eher darum
stück weit die jugend wieder zu
ergattern eher um die impf privilegien
wenn man das mal so nennen kann so viele
machen es natürlich auch für die familie
aber die wenigsten oder von den
wenigsten habe ich mitbekommen ich habe
angst dass ich an corona erkranke
sondern es geht darum mal wieder auf
reisen zu gehen sich mit freunden zu
treffen die möglichkeit zu haben wieder
soziale kontakte zu knüpfen und sich
dann auch dadurch selbst
weiterzuentwickeln ist ja nicht nur weil
etwas physisch sondern auch psychisch
psychisches
corona sich darauf auswirkt man merkt
dass sie sich viele gedanken darüber
machen und wir reden ja heute über die
frage wie viele gedanken macht sich
eigentlich die politik über die jüngeren
menschen wir haben auf der anderen seite
ja auch noch jemanden sitzen der noch im
schulalter ist da würde ich gerne mal
fragen wie viel verunsicherung
löst das denn in ihrem freundeskreis aus
was hier gerade in mit corona diskutiert
wird man impfen na ja also ich vertraue
der stiko auch erst mal so und das ist
in meinem umfeld ähnlich aber ich stimme
da voll zum impfen wir haben uns alle
impfen lassen weil wir die privilegien
haben also ich bin viel unterwegs sein
möchte nicht jeden abend oder zweimal am
tag ein crooner test machen müssen
irgendwo rein gehen zu können dass ich
schwer erkrankte davor habe ich nicht so
große angst und da glaube ich um dem
land gut zu tun wäre es besser andere
erst zu impfen als mich
aber ich würde mich da in der stiko
festhalten auf jeden fall da gibt es
zumindest schon mal einigkeit gibt es
einigkeit dann wollen wir doch noch mal
auf die mpk beschlüsse gucken eben mit
blick konkret auf die jugendämter
ungeimpfte müssen tests künftig selbst
zahlen ab dem 11 oktober ist das so das
heißt am zb für eine 18-jährige
ungeimpfte die ins fitnessstudio will
oder ins kino vor jedem mal muss die
sich nicht nur testen lassen sondern
dass künftig auch selbst bezahlen nur
wird viel über eine impfpflicht durch
die hintertür gesprochen ist das nicht
mindestens schon eine impfpflicht durch
die seitentür nein das ist es weder
rechtlich noch politisch und ich finde
es erstmal praktisch nein auch
faktischen ich finde es erst mal wichtig
daran festzuhalten dass wir generell
getestete und geimpfte gleichstellen das
war immer gerade aus der perspektive der
jungen generation glaube ich eine große
notwendigkeit klar kommt jetzt
perspektive staatskosten thema und auch
da ist es wichtig aus meiner sicht dass
es zumindest eine sozialschutz
komponente gibt also es kann jetzt nicht
sein dass diese frage dann insbesondere
die aus sozial schwachen verhältnissen
oder jüngere besonders hart trifft so zu
sagen dass die kostenfrage jetzt einen
unwiederbringlichen druck auf die
impfung erzeugt das aber für diejenigen
die sich gesundheitlich unbedenklich
impfen lassen könnten und es aus
bequemlichkeit individuellen gründen
nicht wollen dass man da dann die frage
stellt warum die allgemeinheit diese
tests bezahlen sollte das finde ich
total legitim denn wir müssen uns noch
mal anschauen im verhältnis regel und
ausnahme haben wir jetzt für die
übergangsphase gesagt ja die tests
werden bezahlt das ist generell aber mit
blick auf die gesundheitspolitik er ein
ausnahmefall und deswegen sollten wir
zum regelfall zurückkehren ok dann guck
doch mal ganz konkret draufhaben tour
auf den bund länder beschluss der steht
nämlich auch darin dass veranstaltungen
geschlossenen räumen wie zum beispiel
für junge menschen sehr relevant feiern
bars clubs bereiche mit einem hohen
besonders hohen risiko für mehrfach
ansteckungen sind und dann heißt es
wörtlich dieses risiko steigt noch mal
erheblich wenn ich während des gesamten
verlaufs feste sitzplätze mit
entsprechenden abständen eingenommen
werden frau schäfer her am tu ich weiß
nicht in welche disco so waren oder
vielleicht auch noch sind aber ist die
politik dabei diesen beschlüssen noch
namen der lebensrealität der jungen
menschen ich glaube das ist ein
konkretes beispiel dafür dass es das
teilweise nicht ist und ich glaube dass
es eben gerade bei dieser frage auch
freizeitangebote wieder ermöglichen ist
einfach dass der entscheidende punkt die
im kapazitäten hoch zu tun und ich
glaube da müssen jetzt alle unsere
politischen kapazitäten reingesteckt
werden ich finde da reicht auch die
impfkampagne die die bundesregierung
gemacht hat einfach nicht aus wir müssen
den impfstoff zu den menschen bringt das
habe ich eben schon gesagt deswegen
zweiter punkt ich glaube es ist einfach
extrem relevant dass wir dafür sorgen
dass die bundesregierung und auch die
ministerpräsidenten dafür sorgen dass
wir jetzt nicht test nicht mehr bezahlen
genau in der zeit wo die delta variante
wahrscheinlich ansteigen wird und wir
uns eigentlich sehr freuen würden wenn
wir genau wissen wo die infektion
startet ich glaube er wird an der
falschen stelle gespart aber andere
anreize fürs impfen finde ich durchaus
absolut wichtig stichwort lebens mehr da
haben sie ja völlig recht mit dem
beispiel ich kann das noch toppen ich
erinnere mich an eine pressekonferenz
von manuela schwesig als sie sagte
hochzeiten sind wieder erlaubt aber
tanzen dann bitte nicht das ist
natürlich irgendwas was mit den
lebensretter sich muscheln jetzt drüber
das ist realität angeschrieben im zur
realität gehört dass wir da auch schauen
müssen bei diesen ganzen beschlossen
dass sie in gewisser weise auch
praktikabel sind weil wir haben doch
nichts davon wenn wir sozusagen
beschlüsse für die papier schreibtische
machen wo man dann sagt ja da wird dann
irgendwie formal gibt es eine kontakt
nachverfolgung und ansonsten wird's
nicht gelebt das hilft auch nicht und
deswegen muss es lebensnah sein da haben
sie recht aber eines stimmt auch und das
muss man glaube ich den
ministerpräsidenten schon auch
zugestehen sie haben natürlich recht
dass eine besondere infektionsgefahr
rausgeht von solchen veranstaltungen
deswegen muss man da genau hinschauen
ich glaube dem können wir entgehen indem
wir wirklich so wie frau schäfer das
gesagt hat die impfbereitschaft in
unserem land erhöhen das ist das was das
gemeinschaftliche ziel von politik im
moment seien
[Musik]